SCOTT WIENER: Maybe about a
year, year and a half ago, I
took what I do--
I mean, what I do for the most
part is I'm just obsessed with
pizza the way that any
normal human is.
You like to eat pizza, you
see boxes of pizza, you
want to dive in.
It sort of decomposes
every human.
When a box of pizza comes out,
you go back to 12 years old,
and that's sort of it, and it's
always going to happen
for your whole life.
It's just this thing
that embodies the
spirit, I think, of youth.
And in a lot of ways, we're
going to talk about why that
happens all day today.
Today what I want to do is I
want to take you through what
we're eating, talk about where
it comes from, what it is and
what it means and where it's
going, just because around New
York City, there's so many
different styles of pizza.
And the first thing that ever
happens when I walk in a room
and I'm like, oh, we're going
to be talking about pizza,
everybody starts asking
questions about, what's the
best, what's your favorite,
that kind of thing.
I just want to let you guys know
we're not talking about
that today.
That's just to clear the air,
because we could spend three
hours sitting here going around
the room and everybody
being like, well, what
about this place?
Isn't it the best?
As I was walking up here--
so I do walking tours
and bus tours.
And the guy who runs the bus
squad out of nowhere text
messages me, hey, in your
opinion, just a question,
what's the best pizza
in New York?
I'm like, you couldn't get any
worse of a question than that.
Just because when you guys go
out and eat pizza, I feel like
the first decision that you're
making when you're picking a
place to go is you're
choosing proximity.
A lot of times it's like, what's
in this neighborhood,
what's the deal with that?
It's very rare that you're ever
in a situation where,
like, we're going to go anywhere
within 15 miles.
Let's pick one and we're
all going to
rent a car or something.
That's a lot more rare.
But if you ever do that,
you've probably--
I mean, I've been in the
same boat many times.
You're picking places sort
of based on adventure.
Right now in New York, we're
in this amazing position of
having so many pizza styles
happening all at one time.
Whereas in the past, when you
think of New York style pizza,
there's certainly New
York style pizza
sitting on this table.
New York Pizza Suprema is the
name of one of the pizzerias
that brought some pies.
That's a classic
New York pizza.
Then we have Donatella, which
is on 8th Avenue and I think
19th Street, 18th Street,
and that's not a
typical New York pizza.
That's a pre-New York pizza.
It's a Neapolitan pizza.
Then we also have John's, which
I think is all the way
down at that end of the table.
I think it's already all gone.
Is there any John's left?
There's two slices left?
From what pie?
AUDIENCE: Mushroom.
SCOTT WIENER: Both mushroom?
No love for the mushroom.
Although now that you announced
it, now everyone's
going to be running over.
Well, so we've got a couple of
slices from John's, and John's
is somewhere in between
those two.
And I'm not talking about
quality-wise.
I'm not talking about that one
is the best and the other is a
lower quality.
I'm talking about historically,
just because as
you go through time, you find
developments from one style to
another and the developments
all happen mainly
for economic reasons.
History, economics, and social
positioning really have a lot
to do with pizza styles
changing.
So I'm just curious.
Just right off the bat, does
anybody have a current
favorite pizzeria anywhere
at all in the world?
What do you got?
AUDIENCE: Bar in New Haven.
SCOTT WIENER: Bar
in New Haven.
Bar is an interesting place,
because Bar opened about 15
years ago, and they're
in New Haven.
And if anybody's been in New
Haven, Connecticut, New Haven
is like a stronghold
for pizza.
It's the kind of place where
sometimes I hear people say,
oh, I heard New Haven actually
has the oldest pizzerias in
the United States, which is not
really true, but New Haven
has a lot of really old ones.
They have got a place Frank
Pepe's, which opened in 1925,
and then down the street there's
a place that Frank
Pepe's nephews, Tony and
Salvatore, opened a place in
1938 called Sally's.
And these are these two big
places in New Haven that if
you live or if you've ever been
in New Haven or if your
family grew up there or
anything, everybody has one or
the other that they love.
Then in comes Bar 15 years
ago, and they do a very
non-traditional pizza.
Everybody who goes there really
loves the-- and I don't
know if you fall into
this category--
mashed potato pizza.
If you are in that category,
that's cool.
Totally atypical, totally a
non-classic, nontraditional
pizza, but absolutely valid in
the eyes of the great pizza
landscape, because you can
really put anything on pizza
and it still counts
as that category.
So Bar is an interesting one.
I'm glad that you brought that
up, because it sort of crosses
boundaries.
Well, we're going to talk
about these three main
staples, these three strata,
these bits of the evolutionary
process within pizza.
And then there are some places
like Bar that don't
fit right into it.
Any other favorites?
Like, what do you got?
AUDIENCE: Pizza Modo
[INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: Pizza Modo--
David with the outdoor oven
thing, and he's got a few now.
And David's really interesting
because Pizza Modo is a
portable, wood-fired oven, and
he'll bring it to street fairs
and things like that, and
bakes these incredible
Neapolitan pizzas.
That's more similar to
Donatella, except for the
beauty of a place like Pizza
Modo is that you're outside,
he's going to hand you the
pizza, it's never going to get
trapped in a box.
If we could have had these
delivered here without those
boxes, that would've been
amazing, but we didn't,
because Greg has two arms
and that's about it.
But what else?
Any other favorites?
So far we've hit two totally
different strata.
What do you got?
AUDIENCE: Pi Pizzeria
in Washington, DC.
SCOTT WIENER: Is that the
full name of it, Pi?
AUDIENCE: It's called
Pi [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: Oh, gotcha.
Just so you guys know, it should
be pretty obvious,
there are, like, 50 places
called Pi with the pi symbol
and they're not related.
It's sort of like what Ray's
is to New York, Pi is to
everyone else around
the country.
Everyone's like, oh, here's
a really cute,
quirky name for a pizzeria--
pi.
And I actually know somebody who
owns a place called Pi in
Rochester, Minnesota, and
it's the pi symbol.
But anyway, I haven't
been to that place.
What's the style?
AUDIENCE: Lower Chicago style.
SCOTT WIENER: Really?
AUDIENCE: But not
overly cheesy.
SCOTT WIENER: Is it Chicago
thin crust or
Chicago deep dish?
AUDIENCE: They call
it Chicago style.
It's allegedly [INAUDIBLE].
It was the first pizza place
I found [INAUDIBLE]
proximity.
SCOTT WIENER: Proximity.
So proximity is a huge
factor in the whole
discussion of pizza.
The origin of pizza has nothing
to do with anything
besides proximity, because the
way we're going to track these
three different types of pizza
are basically through the
ovens that they're using,
through the cheeses that
they're using, the machinery
that's available that they're
using in the kitchens, and
I think that might be it.
There's no fourth one,
but we'll see.
So this is actually a good
place to start, because I
brought some photos of things,
just photos that I've taken
over the years, to try to
help explain some of the
progression of what we
have on the table.
And the first one, the first
pizza, that we're going to
talk about is that, like,
Pizza Modo, it's this
Neapolitan pizza
from Donatella.
Yeah, so do me a favor.
Somebody just hold that up a
little bit, just so everyone
knows what I'm talking about.
And at this point,
there's so many--
oh, is that the sausage
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SCOTT WIENER: Cool.
At some point, just pass
that this way.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You want
it right now?
SCOTT WIENER: Yeah, let's
do it right now.
Oh, thank you.
Wow, you're like the doctor in
the delivery room handing me
my first child.
This is great.
Well, so at this point in human
history, especially in
New York, so many articles
are written about
pizza all the time.
And Neapolitan is sort of like
a big focus in it, but I want
to really concentrate
on what that means.
Sometimes people look at a pizza
like this and they say,
oh, this is a gourmet pizza,
oh, this is a highfalutin,
fancy pants pizza.
The interesting thing about it
is this is the oldest form of
pizza, this is the
original format.
And the original format of
oven are these giant--
well, not so giant--
these big wood-burning ovens.
And you've seen them
all over the place.
This is not your first time
seeing a wood-burning oven.
But other wood-burning
ovens around city--
Don Antonio, Keste, Motorino,
Paulie Gee's in Greenpoint,
Fornino in Williamsburg.
I mean, they're all
over the place.
We could go on for an hour
listing them all.
And this oven is really
important for what we were
just talking about with
proximity, because the oven is
the whole reason that
pizza exists.
In the early 16th century, early
1500s, we have these
ovens, or baker's ovens,
and they're
wood-burning baker's ovens.
And you can find these going
all the way back to being
baker's ovens back to 2,000
years ago in Pompeii.
If you ever go to Pompeii or
Herculaneum, you can find, I
think, 30 or 40 of these ovens
sitting around preserved,
these ovens.
And the way that they work
is they're real simple.
We're going to get to the
functionality a little bit
later, but all you need to
understand is, it's a
wood-burning oven.
They use wood, they fire it up,
they get the oven chamber
really hot.
And once that chamber reaches
what they call a soak point,
that soak point is where the
stone within the oven, the
masonry within the oven, has
enough power, has enough
thermal energy, that it can
continuously bake product
throughout the day without
a live fire.
And that's important, because
once you have a fire in there
like they do in this photo,
you can't bake anything
directly next to that fire.
If you let the fire burn out,
and let the oven kind of even
out at its soak point,
then you can use any
spot within the oven.
So that's what bakers did.
Bakers would just use the oven
at soak point to bake anywhere
within the oven.
But in the beginning of each
baking session, to test the
oven to see if it was hot
enough, they would take a
piece of dough from yesterday
and they would flatten it out
and toss it inside the oven
just to see if the
oven was real hot.
And if the oven's hot enough,
then that dough is going to
blister and it's going to start
to rise and it's going
to take about two, two and a
half minutes before it's
blackened and nobody
wants to eat it.
And that is the first pizza.
Really, that bit.
The word pizza itself is just a
mispronunciation of the word pita.
And pita goes back to the
ancient Aramaic word pitta,
that just means bread.
A pizza is really
just a bread.
Pizza is not defined as crust,
sauce, and cheese.
The tomato doesn't come
on until way later.
Tomatoes, really the late 17th
century at the very earliest.
Cheese is happening even later
than that, because cheese is
just too expensive until
a certain point.
It really is all about having
a flattened piece of dough,
that when they start throwing
ingredients on top of it, the
ingredients that they're adding
on top of that dough,
it's also proximity, and
it's also economics.
The butcher shop has leftover
pig fat, and that that's the
first pizza topping--
lard, just straight chunks of
lard thrown on top of a dough,
and that's it.
I don't think we
got any today.
Did you order any lard?
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT WIENER: And
I'm not kidding.
There are places that do it.
Keste on Bleecker Street and Don
Antonio, which is owned by
the same guy, they
do that pizza.
It's called the Mast'nicola,
and it's OK that
you didn't get it.
It's all right.
But if you ever have the
chance, try it out.
Share it with people.
You don't want to eat
that whole thing.
And it's delicious.
It's just a bunch of lard.
But you end up having all these
ingredients back in the
day that are just because
of proximity.
So that's why when we're talking
about something like
mashed potatoes at Bar in New
Haven, it's not like potatoes
are hard to come by.
Throw it on a pizza.
If you're in a place that people
like eating Hawaiian
pizza-- which is not
really popular in
Hawaii, by the way--
you've got pineapples handy?
Why not, why the heck not?
These ovens as a bread oven,
this is your starting point
for all pizza.
And throughout that,
we were starting to
change a little bit.
Like, when get onto the next
step in pizza ovens, when we
get to John's, that John's pizza
is going come out of a
massive coal-burning
brick oven.
And this is a shot
of Lombardi's
Pizzeria on Spring Street.
Lombardi's is-- have any of you
guys been to Lombardi's?
Yeah, Lombardi's right now
is at 32 Spring Street.
This is a shot of the original
location, which is 53 and 1/2
Spring Street.
It's a bar called
Gatsby's now.
And this oven is massive.
You can see it's a wall.
It's not like the little
standalone oven that we saw
before with these little guys.
This is a whole wall and it
extends about 12 feet into the
backyard of this building.
And again, proximity
and economics.
We switched from wood to coal
just because wood is too
expensive in Manhattan
in the late 1800s.
In the late 1800s,
early 1900s, coal
was just way cheaper.
They were bringing in coal,
truckloads of coal, which were
used for heating all of
downtown Manhattan.
Anthracite coal was just cheap,
so that's what they
used in this oven, which is why
that John's pizza that you
have is a completely
different texture,
completely different flavor.
You're just getting
down to the crust.
And this is sort of the
early version of
New York style pizza.
Even just from looking at it,
this pizza is larger than that
Donatella pizza and it has a
little bit more to do with the
ingredients that are available
here versus the ingredients
that are available back in
southern Italy, in Naples.
And then of course, the
final oven is the
deck oven back here.
And this is a shot of New York
Pizza Suprema, which we have
smattered along over here.
There's still a couple
of slices.
And I had the opportunity of
working here for a short time,
and I did grow that mustache
just so I would match
everybody else who
worked there.
Everybody has a mustache
there.
I wanted to fit in.
I was writing a series of
articles called "Undercover
Pizza Lover" for "Serious
Eats," and I did three
different jobs.
I worked as a slice slinger at
Suprema, I worked at a place
called Metro Pizza in Las Vegas
where I was a pizza
maker on a busy Saturday night,
and then I did three
weeks at Domino's, where I went
totally undercover, I
went rogue.
I applied for the job and I
worked there for a bit and
learned so much about why I
don't ever want to go near
there again.
But anyway, I just wanted
to show you guys.
Obviously, you all know this
oven probably better than
anything else, but there's a
lot of interesting things
about this type of oven.
And that oven, in fact,
is part of why we
even are here today.
We would not be here today if
pizza stopped with this.
If they switched over to a
coal-burning oven and suddenly
everyone was like, oh, no I'm
not interested anymore--
done.
You see, it's all about fuel
sources becoming cheaper.
The fuel source for--
I mean, coal.
In the late 1930s, coal
becomes too expensive.
Natural gas starts to be the big
seller, and so natural gas
is great for an oven like this
because you can just flip a
switch and it's on, flip
a switch and it's off.
Lombardi's, you can't do that.
At John's, you can't do that.
At Totonno's in Coney Island
or Patsy's in Harlem, you
can't do that.
The switch that you have
to flick doesn't exist.
Instead, to turn the oven off,
you've got to scoop out the
coal and then you've got to pull
it out of the oven, and
then you have to wait two
days or three days.
Really, I'm not kidding.
You have to wait two or three
days, and then if you want to
heat it back up-- let's say your
coal oven goes down to
room temp, you're talking two
and a half weeks, just because
it's all about the masonry
of the oven.
So that's why sometimes
pizzerias tell you about how
hot their ovens are.
The heat in the air of the oven
doesn't make as much of a
difference as the masonry.
What's up?
AUDIENCE: So those coal ovens,
they run continuously?
Patsy's and Luzzo's?
SCOTT WIENER: Yes, they
run continuously.
Luzzo's is an interesting
one because they
don't use solely coal.
They use coal and they put
wood on top of it.
So that's a coal-burning oven.
It's built as a coal-burning
oven, but they also do
wood on top of it.
And they're hot all the time.
Places like Lombardi's
have a bigger oven.
It's physically bigger, so
that's why they keep it going
all the time because it's more
efficient to let it go all
night than it would be to start
the fire in the morning
and then try to reheat
it for three hours.
It's just more of a struggle,
it's harder, so it's easier
for them to maintain
it like that.
And each oven has these
different nuances to it, which
are so fascinating.
The way that they work
is so fascinating.
The inside of a wood-burning
oven, first of all, it just
looks great.
This is why people--
I don't know if you know it,
but a lot of people are
installing ovens in
their backyards.
Not in Brooklyn as much.
But if anybody's interested in
doing that, please talk to me.
Seriously, I'm not kidding.
I looked at this apartment a
couple weeks ago and they were
telling me, we're going to do
some projects in the backyard
and thinking about putting in
a wood-burning oven, and I
freaked out.
And that's probably why I didn't
get the place, because
I was so excited about it.
But I went over there a week
later and I was like, here's
some books.
Just invite me over.
But you notice it's a
dome shape in the
inside of the oven.
This dome shape is really good
because it's going to help
heat transmit by all three
methods of heat
transfer in an oven.
Direct conduction--
the pizza's laying directly
on the floor of the oven.
There's heat conducting right
from the floor into the base
of the pizza.
You're going to have a lot of
radiation, because all the
heat that's bouncing off those
bricks on the top is going to
centralize back on the
floor of the oven.
And then of course, you
have convection.
Since this fire-- you notice
how the fire is
sort of to the left?
I'm taking the picture through
the only opening in that oven.
It's one opening, right
in the front.
So air can only get in or out
through that one opening.
I know in the picture I showed
you before, there were these
vents up on top, the flue.
Each of those flues is not
connected directly to the peak
of the dome of the oven.
All cool air to feed the logs
is going right in along the
bottom, hitting the fire,
heating up, swirling around,
and coming out the front
and up into the hood.
So that hood is connected to
that flue in the back.
That's why when you look inside
this oven, there's no
opening inside there.
All that heat is coming
right out the front.
But again, the problem is these
ovens don't really work
as well when you come into New
York City, just because of the
expense of the fuel, which is
why we're going to change
things up a little bit.
But I just wanted to show you
another quick image about how
fresh air is going to come in
the front, warm up, move out,
and exit again out the front.
But a coal-burning oven
is different.
This is a more recent photo.
This is a place called
Verde in Bushwick.
I think it's on Irving.
And this is an oven that the
guy bought the building, he
was messing around, and found
that, hey, this is not the
wall, this is an oven.
And why not?
This is the way it works.
You see, these ovens at a place
like Lombardi's or at
similar places-- actually, in
New Haven at Pepe's and at
Sally's, if you look at the
profile of any of these
buildings that have these old
coal-burning ovens, the
building is three or four
stories tall and then it drops
down to a one-story extension
for, 20, 30, 40 feet, and then
there's a chimney at the end.
And that extension
is the oven.
It's all the oven, if you
look at the profile.
This one is interesting,
though.
This one's not on the
ground floor.
This one is in the ground.
It's underneath the sidewalk.
So this oven extends in the
front of the building
underneath the sidewalk,
almost definitely built
illegally about 100,
110 years ago.
That's the way that
they rolled.
They just built something and
they said, if I get busted,
I'll get the permit later.
And that's what happened.
I found the permit for
Lombardi's, the Lombardi's
oven for 1898.
But that oven is probably a
little bit older than that.
If they got the permit in 1898,
I don't think they were
like, let's get all of our ducks
in a row and make sure
everything's right.
We just moved here three years
ago, we know the rules.
No, it was just they just
did it and they
figured it out later.
The way this works is
totally different.
Instead of having one opening in
the front, it's got three.
And this is just a handle.
There's a light switch
back there.
That's not an opening.
There's an opening right here,
and then that little doorway
to the right, and then
below that doorway.
So inside that door, that little
slightly curved, little
adorable little elf door,
that's where they
shovel the coal in.
Right below it is the ash drop,
which sometimes they'll
leave open so that air
can flow in, air
can feed the fire.
And as that air goes up through
the fire, heats up,
hits the top of the oven right
around here, it's going to
flow all the way to the back
left corner to exit out the
flue in this oven.
So instead of being a circular
motion in the inside of the
oven, it's going straight
across.
And that heat, as it goes
straight across, is a
completely different bake
when we go from
Donatella to John's.
You notice Donatella's pizza,
it's a lot softer, it's a
little more consistent
in texture.
John's pizza tends to be a
little tougher, a little bit
more of a bite, and that's
because the bake time is going
to be longer.
Donatella's pizza comes out in
60 to 90 seconds, and John's
is five minutes-- not that
five minutes is bad.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
pizza, [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: You know,
it's interesting.
Anthracite is about 92%, 93%
carbon content, so there's not
a lot of moisture.
Burning wood lets off a lot more
smoke than burning coal,
a lot more smoke.
The difference is that the ash
is easier to get rid of from a
wood oven than it is from
a coal oven, so
that's the big thing.
And of course, burning a fossil
fuel is not a great
deal, so I would not, by any
means, advocate coal-fired
pizzerias happening in every
city around the world.
But it's not as harmful.
People think it's going to be
harmful because coal has this
bad rep, as it probably
should be.
But it's not.
It's really any of the coal, any
of the heat, is coming on
the right side of the oven.
No pizzas are baking on the
right side of the oven.
They're all baking
on the left.
And they can't bake on
the right, because
it's just too hot.
And that coal fire is also a
different fire from wood.
It's more smoldering.
You don't have huge flames
leaping about.
With that wood-fired oven,
you've got flames that go up
to 12 o'clock on the top of that
dome, and that flame is
going to help you get blisters
on the edge of your crust.
It's not that they chose, oh,
let's make the flame big to
get blisters.
It was more like, oh, we threw
the dough in when the oven is
really hot and the flame is
reaching up to the top, and we
end up getting these blisters.
And then the people of Naples
figure oh, well, we can't
change anything, because
we like it.
So that's why today we have
an organization called the
Associaziane Verace Pizza
Napoletana, or the pizza
police, as some people
call them.
And they have a series of rules
that say the pizza must
be 35 centimeters in diameter,
the tomato that you use on top
of it must be San Marzano, and
it must be applied to the
dough in a circular motion.
And I'm not kidding
about that.
And it says the oil must be
extra virgin, and the cheese
must be fresh fior di latte,
which is a cow's milk
mozzarella, or buffalo
milk mozzarella.
They don't give you
any leeway.
It's really funny to me because
so many pizzerias, you
think that, like, oh, they've
got secret recipes.
Secrets.
No secrets.
In fact, they publish what
you have to do to
make the right pizza.
The best pizza has no secrets,
because the best pizza is
really pretty simple for me,
at least what I like.
But this type of oven, again,
completely different from what
we saw before.
So that's why it's so hard to
pick out what is the best,
because the oven's just going
to bake things differently.
It's more like you've got to
pick what you're into.
You've got to pick if you're
into basketball
or football or baseball.
They're all different paces of
sport, they're all different.
So that's why with these ovens,
you kind of have to
know which type of oven your
pizza's coming from.
And of course, there could be
wood-fired ovens that the
pizza comes out tasting
and looking like a
gas-fueled deck oven.
That just means that it's not
being used the way it's
intended to, and that's all
in the hands of the user.
These are just tools.
Just because you have a
coal-burning oven or a
wood-burning oven in your
backyard does not mean that
you're making the right
type of pizza.
So with this kind of oven, the
inside of it-- and this is
actually funny.
This is a rare day when at the
very beginning of the day,
when they still have wood in the
pile to help burn some of
the coals, where you
do have a flame.
But that flame is not by any
means reaching as far as the
flame before.
This is a picture I took of the
inside of Lombardi's oven
after they did a huge
restoration job to it to make
it look the way it used
to look, the inside.
And you see the way the
inside is shaped.
It's like a barrel vault.
It's not a dome, so heat
is moving from
one side to the other.
It is not moving in a
circular motion--
one side to the other.
And you're not going to have
any pizza over there.
Pizzas are going to start
right around that
point in the center.
And if they have calzones,
they're going to be baked
closer to the front door,
because it's colder by the
front door.
Calzones are thick.
You don't want to bake
it very quickly.
You want to bake it at a nice
pace, an even pace, so that
the outside can bake and
the inside can bake.
But they're just fascinating.
They're just a real pain.
Nobody wants to use these ovens
anymore, and that's why
they fell out of vogue, also
because to maintain them--
you've got the coal on
the side of it--
every morning and every
afternoon, in the middle of
the afternoon before the dinner
rush happens, you've
got to scrape out
the excess coal.
So you can see better in this
photograph, that little open
door on the bottom.
That's air coming straight in to
fuel the coal, and the coal
is sitting on top of
a metal grate just
so you can get airflow.
Oh, these are my feet, sticking
out of the oven.
I wanted to show you this,
because when I told you about
waiting two or three days to
repair the oven, I'm serious.
This was two, two and a
half days after they
shut down the oven.
And they were sending people in
to replace broken bricks.
This is a picture I took right
before they did that huge
restoration for the inside, and
they let me crawl in there
for 10 seconds, and
it was amazing.
And I never want to do it
again, because it was
terrifying.
But the inside of the
oven, it's so hot.
It was 322 degrees Fahrenheit at
that moment that the photo
was taken on the floor
of the oven.
Luckily, I'm sitting on a piece
of plywood, so that's
why I'm OK.
But it's extraordinarily hot.
Again, that's why who in their
right mind would want to build
one of these now when
you have to do this?
Have any of you guys heard about
why there aren't so many
coal ovens around anymore?
A lot of people ask me about--
they hear that it's illegal to
build a coal-burning oven, for
environmental reasons
or for whatever.
It's not at all.
It's 100% legal.
It's just nobody would do
it, because that's how
you have to fix it.
So rather than do that, it's
easier to just get one of
these ovens, to get one of these
gas-fueled deck ovens.
How many of you have
been here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: Yeah.
That's why I put this picture
in here, because I knew that
it would send a bolt
of electricity
through your hearts.
And for anybody who has not been
there, this is a place
that you will go.
It's OK.
Don't go with too many people.
Go at 11:30 on a Wednesday.
Call in sick to work.
I didn't say that out loud.
It's just, he's the only
guy who makes the
pizza at this place.
This is Dom DeMarco.
He's at a place called
the Di Fara on Avenue
J in Midwood, Brooklyn.
This is actually a rare picture,
because he's using
the a peel to take the
pizza, the Sicilian
pizza, out of the oven.
Usually he just grabs it, which
is also terrifying,
because it's super hot.
But these are deck ovens.
And a lot of times people look
at that and they're like, oh,
no, I like brick oven pizza.
Meanwhile, this guy makes some
of the best pizza in the city.
And regardless of whatever lists
in the Zagat survey and
all that, most people--
my bus guy this morning
is telling me
about, you're crazy.
You like the Sicilian here
better than Di Fara.
Whatever.
I wanted to show you
this, because he's
using these deck ovens.
He's using an oven that is the
cheapest oven, and yet an oven
that started to proliferate
right after the Second World
War, after you've got a lot of
American soldiers coming back
from serving in Italy
during the war.
And they're coming back and
saying, well, I'm not going to
build a giant oven, because of
the expense and what if I go
out of business, what if
I don't do anything?
You get one of these
ovens in 1954.
One of those ovens-- and there
are three in this picture.
One of those ovens was
going for $500 new,
$250 used on the Bowery.
You could have bought any one of
these ovens for $250 used.
So you could put that
in your place.
If you go out of business, put
a For Sale sign on it, and
then you're done.
If you have these coal-burning
brick ovens, and you go out of
business, you walk
away from it.
A lot of times you put up
a wall in front of it.
There are so many of
those coal ovens
laying around the city.
So many.
And you put up a wall in front
of it and walk away and
pretend it's not there.
And that happened to my
friend David Sheridan.
David is opening up a place on
Church Avenue in Ditmas Park
in, I guess, a couple
of months.
He signed a lease
on this place.
A week later, went
in and tried to
clean up the basement.
And he finds this coal-burning
oven.
He's opening a pizzeria there.
He got an electric oven to use,
because he's like, well,
I don't want to deal with the
hassle of anything else.
And there it is.
Right there, a coal-burning
oven sitting there.
It's absolutely incredible.
The current Lombardi's
oven is not the
original Lombardi's oven.
The original Lombardi's oven
broke because the Six Train
runs directly underneath it.
So when they moved to their
current location, they moved
there because it's an old bakery
oven that was used in a
place called the
Parisi Bakery.
And when Parisi went out of
business in the late '70s,
they put up a wall in front
of it, walked away.
They said, we don't need
to do demolition.
Nobody will know.
Lombardi's knew.
And when they went out of
business, they came in and
they're said, well, we're
going to take this.
It's perfect, you know?
It's like when you see, oh, this
house already has a pool
in the backyard.
Let's get it.
You know?
That coal-burning oven is the
pool in the backyard of the
pizzeria's house.
What?
So that's why it's interesting
that we get to these ovens.
And this is really what
people were using
because it made sense.
Of course it works totally
differently.
The bottom door on any of these
ovens, that's called the
service door.
You have two pipes underneath
that have a natural gas-fueled
flame that's heating
up the stone.
But on the top of the oven and
on the sides and on the back,
it's all stainless.
So it's not really good at
radiating a lot of heat.
It's not going to bake
a lot from the top.
It's going to bake mostly
from the bottom.
And that's why the pizzas from
Suprema are baked differently
from the pizzas from John's
and from Donatella.
John's has more char going on.
Donatella's lighter
and fluffier.
Suprema is that classic New York
slice, that you can pick
it up and fold it.
And the cheese only starts
to move a little bit.
It starts to migrate
toward the bottom.
And the oil starts to gather,
and you could drip a little
bit off the front.
But don't blot it, at
least not in front
of people you respect.
And then you pick it up and it
doesn't crack on the bottom.
You take a bite.
It's pure bliss.
But that's the slice.
It's so far removed from the
origin, and people get into
arguments all the time.
Southern Italians especially.
Oh, that's not pizza.
Meanwhile, in southern Italy,
they're eating pizza with
French fries and hot dogs
on it, and they're
saying that that's OK.
It's not OK.
You know?
And if that's OK, then
all this is OK.
Which I personally believe
that it's all OK.
And that's why it's so
interesting that, in an oven
like this, it's a tool.
This guy makes these pizzas.
And I take people from Naples
to this pizzeria sometimes.
And they're into it.
I'm like, just don't
worry, and they're
like, oh, it's small.
And then they go in and
they eat it, and
they understand it.
And then they start
talking to him.
And he's from Caserta, which
is just north of Naples.
And suddenly it's like, oh.
Now I get it.
Because he knows
how to work it.
Working the dough is another big
huge concept that changes
throughout time.
But before we get into
that, I want to show
you guys this picture.
This is a picture of a pizza
oven factory on the Bowery.
This is the only pizza oven
factory in the whole city.
And it still operates
every day.
They build these pizza ovens.
So it's still going and
it's still totally
classic New York thing.
By the way, this is
on Prince Street.
If you're ever on Prince and
Bowery, there's two red doors.
And you can hear them
working on stuff.
Just open up the doors.
They're never locked
during the week.
Just open it, seriously.
That was when I took
the picture.
You just open it, and you look
in, and you're like, what?
It's like this secret world.
It's amazing.
And then he'll just flip it
up and look at you, and
then you run away.
So I take tours here
sometimes.
And it's really funny to
look in, and people are
like, wait a second.
You can go buy a handbag over
here, and you can go buy fancy
shoes over here, and then there
are these guys working
on pizza ovens who don't
speak much English.
These guy's are from
southern Italy.
It's amazing.
They breathe in so many fumes.
The doors are always closed.
So, anyway.
From here, I wanted to show you
a little bit about dough,
just because the handling of
the dough, again, is super,
super important.
And this is a guy named
Jonathan Goldsmith.
Is anybody from Chicago?
Yeah.
Have you ever been
to Spacca Napoli?
AUDIENCE: Actually, I have.
SCOTT WIENER: Yeah.
Yeah, that's his place.
That's Jonathan Goldsmith
of Spacca Napoli.
And he's wearing all this get-up
with the name of a
flower company.
And he's a part of the
Associazione Verace Pizza
Napolitana.
And he's got this
big wooden box.
And right now he's kneading
dough by hand because he makes
pizza in the original Neapolitan
style, where you
don't use a machine.
You have to handle the
dough very carefully.
It means that the dough is going
to come out very light
and supple, it's going to bake
easily and bake quickly.
It's great.
But again, this doesn't
make sense.
After the Second World War
especially, this just doesn't
make sense as economics
change and you need
to make more dough.
Which is why the Donatella
version of dough-- which they
don't do it by hand like
this, but I wanted to
show you the extreme.
The Donatella version of dough
is using a machine that very
gently kneads the dough, very
gently incorporates all the
ingredients.
Completely changes when you
get to the next step.
This is a picture of the dough
mixer at Patsy's, which is
very similar to what they'd be
using at a place like John's.
So John's is a coal oven.
The era that John's opened, in
the late '20s and early '30s,
Patsy's opened in 1933.
And that mixer, it's got a
tumbler in the inside.
So it's going to move
your dough around in
a circle like this.
It's not as gentle as
using the hands.
But it's not as brutal as the
next step that happens when we
get into modern pizza-making,
which is the gigantic
Kitchen-Aid on steroids.
The Hobart H800 is this
model, which is huge.
It's so sweet.
No.
It's this huge mixer, and the
big difference in it is that
it's a planetary mixer.
So it's going to mix
from the top with a
hook that goes down.
It heats up the dough a lot more
than the other mixers,
which is not a great thing.
Sometimes that can toughen up
the dough, which has resulted
in the New York slice,
which we love.
It's a happy accident.
This type of mixer, it's
an electric mixer.
It lets you walk away
while it's mixing.
You don't have to sit there
and maintain it.
And also, if you notice that
this last mixer I showed you,
this one from the '30s, early
'30s, it's just a mixer.
Well, hold on.
This one has a nozzle on the
front, where you can attach
either a cheese shredder, a
meat grinder, a vegetable
slicer, whatever you want.
This thing does two
jobs at once.
And really, that's why they
started using it, because it's
all about having this
tiny pizzeria.
You know the tiny pizzerias.
Joe's on Carmine street, little
places where you walk
in and it's two guys
behind a counter.
And there's a counter, five or
six pizzas sitting out, a
couple of ovens, and this kind
of mixer in the back.
And if they want to employ fewer
people, then you've got
to get the mixer that takes
the job of some of those
humans, which is
what this does.
And that's why, as you get on,
the contemporary New York
slice is based on the result
of this type of oven, the
unplanned result of this,
rather, this type of mixer.
Which is just fascinating,
because that mixer--
again, there's not a good
or a bad mixer.
Now they have all these
crazy mixers.
There's one mixer, I don't
have a picture.
But it looks like a pair
of hands, and it
combines the dough.
It's crazy.
It's like, why don't you just
get your buddy to do this?
I don't know.
But anyway, it's pretty
interesting how the different
handling of dough is going to
change the result of it.
So when you go to a place,
let's say you're into
Pizzarte-- there's a place
called Pizzarte on--
oh jeez, where is it?
It's right in the, I think
around the theater district.
If you're into that type of
pizza, and if you're into
Donatella, and if you're into
Keste, they're all made in a
similar method with similar
maneuvering, and similar
ingredients on top of
the pizza as well.
Now, this as a whole
different thing.
And I had to include something
about throwing dough up in the
air, because everybody
asks about it.
We just have to get this
out the way right now.
Throwing dough up in the air,
he's doing this to entertain
people and because there's a
camera sitting right there.
And this is Gennaro Lombardi.
This is a picture that was
taken in the '50s.
He's throwing this dough up in
the air because American
wheat, American flour,
is a lot tougher
than European flour.
That's why, American flour, you
can't really successfully
use your hands to mix a whole
ton of it at a time.
It doesn't pull in as much
moisture as European flour.
And it's tougher to move.
So if you ever get a chance,
go into the kitchen at a
Neapolitan pizzeria.
Just stick your hand in the
dough, and squeeze it.
And then run.
Pull off the fake moustache.
And then go to another place
that's different, do the same
thing, repeat.
And then see what happens.
But you'll notice that the more
contemporary pizzerias,
the dough is just physically
tougher.
So to stretch it out, they
started stretching it out over
the backs of their hands.
How many of you make
pizza at home?
Yeah.
So when you make pizza
at home, you know.
You start off on the table.
You have to extend the dough.
You're basically moving
around gas.
You're moving gas from the
center of the dough to the
outside, and that in turn
is what stretches it.
Sometimes people get
a rolling pin.
Sometimes people just grab it
and stretch it like this.
And that ends up giving you weak
spots, and fixed spots,
and it's not very even.
This is a way that they're able
to even out the dough.
He was stretching it over the
back of his hands, and what he
just did was he, instead of
rotating it nice and evenly,
he threw it in the air.
And he's going to catch
it back on the
backsides of his hands.
That's why his hand is facing
down like this.
But again, it's just for show.
Nobody really ever does
that for fun.
I mean, it is for fun.
Nobody ever really does that,
because if you put 10 pizza
makers in a locked room and make
them make pizza, nobody's
going to throw it in the air.
You could drop it.
Who knows?
But the handling of the dough,
it just completely changes.
Now, this type of crust,
this blistering, is
which one of the ovens?
We had the wood, we had
the coal, and we
had the deck oven.
AUDIENCE: Wood.
SCOTT WIENER: Definitely.
It's a wood oven, because that
fire reaches up to the top,
bounces down, and creates
all those blisters.
But I really want to get into
that cheese for a second,
because you probably noticed
this, that the cheese in all
these three pizzas were totally
different cheeses.
The one at Donatella was
a fresh mozzarella.
And that's this stuff.
The fresh mozzarella, which
is bright white.
It's really milky.
Oh, I didn't put the picture
in the right place.
Anyway, it's really milky.
It's this bright white
milkiness.
And it's bright white and not
yellowy like some of the other
cheese because there's
no extra oil added.
You see, cheese like this
is just made from curds.
You have chunks from
cow's milk, just
from curds and water.
No preservatives added.
But it's a problem.
Another economic problem is
that this type of cheese
doesn't ship.
It doesn't last long.
It lasts two days at most.
So as pizza expands in the
United States, we lose this
kind of cheese, and we start
getting a new low-moisture
mozzarella cheese.
And low-moisture mozzarella
cheese is the
stuff that you shred.
So you go from cheese
that you slice to
cheese that you shred.
I have some cheese pictures
that are missing in the
universe somewhere, but you know
what cheese looks like.
And cheese that's on this pizza
over here, that New York
Pizza Suprema, it's
high-quality cheese from Wisconsin.
That is whole milk,
low-moisture.
It's a company called
Grande, and their
mozzarella is excellent.
It's just that when you bake it,
some of the fat is going
to rise up to the top, because
they're in ovens that are
lower temperatures, and
they're going to
take longer to bake.
It's a deck oven.
And that oil's going
to rise to the top.
And that's what you're seeing,
the coloration on
the very top of it.
You'll also see, since it's a
shredded cheese, a lot of that
tomato is going to
bleed through it.
And the tomato is a whole other
story as well, because
if you look at-- this is another
picture from Di Fara.
And I took this picture of the
tomatoes he's using, because
he's using these boxes of canned
whole tomatoes, which
is the old traditional method
of doing sauces.
So I don't know if you guys can
see this from back there,
but there's two cans here.
One of them says pizza sauce,
the one on the right.
And then the one on the left
is our whole tomatoes.
So there's a tomato.
You can see two tomatoes
floating around in this puree.
The one on the left is the old
method of doing tomato, and
the one on the right
is the new one.
On the left, it's whole
tomatoes that
are going to be crushed.
And at Donatella, that
sauce is just
crushed tomato with salt.
It's uncooked, because that's
the way it was back in Naples.
Because in Naples, I think
earlier I mentioned about how
you don't really get tomato on
pizza for quite a while.
You get tomato in the first
recipe in a Neapolitan
cookbook for a tomato
sauce is 1693.
And then you don't really have
anything hitting dough until
long after that.
So you're probably talking about
the mid-18th century
where you start to get more
tomato landing on dough.
So it's kind of a new thing.
But at that point, they're just
taking tomatoes, crushing
them up, and throwing
them on dough
because they're plentiful.
They're around.
AUDIENCE: Tomato was
[INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Exactly.
And after 1492.
Because that first
ride did not get
everything coming back.
Took a couple of rides to
figure out the tomato.
The tomato's originally
from Central America.
It ends up being cultivated,
we don't even really know.
Probably in Mexico, but again,
we're not really sure.
But then it does end up coming
back to Europe because of the
Spanish conquistadors.
Because remember, they had a
lot of people sailing under
the Spanish flag, but
they're Italians.
Because at that time, southern
Italy was under Spanish rule.
So you get all these products
coming back like the tomato,
and they're all landing in
southern Italy, all because
southern Italy is a place where
there was fertile soil.
So that's what you have
going on on the left.
But remember, in the United
States, up until, really, the
Second World War, you have all
the tomatoes of Italy.
It's really hard to get tomatoes
out of Italy between
the First and Second
World War.
Mussolini kept all
the tomatoes.
Very seriously, wasn't
exporting tomatoes
to the US, for sure.
So we were kind of left to our
own devices, and that's bad,
because our tomatoes we're
not that hot at the time.
And so instead of people
preparing sauces just with a
crushed tomato, they started
cooking down the sauce and
started adding oregano and
adding basil and adding who
knows what.
Sugar.
And that's what's
on the right.
You can buy a can
of pizza sauce.
Some pizzerias take a lot
of pride in that they
do their own sauce.
Some of them buy the pizza sauce
and they add more spices
and things because they want
to put their mark on it.
And then you just end
up getting this
really highly acidic--
it really gives you a little,
ooh, after you eat it, or
really pasty.
You get a lot cleaner taste from
the stuff on the left.
It's just that for a
while, we didn't
really have good tomatoes.
Now we do, and now
it's getting OK.
But I wanted to show you this
because you can even see the
coloration.
The right side is a lot darker
than the left side.
So you can tell that's
been cooked.
That's been cooked, which means
that the water's going
to evaporate and you're going
to have condensation of
sugars, and maybe even slight
carmelization, because of so
much sugar that's already
in the tomato.
So right there, a cooked
versus, on
the left, and uncooked.
On the pizzas that we've had,
Suprema, that one is an
uncooked one, the Margherita
pizza.
Suprema's regular one
is cooked, and
Donatello's is uncooked.
And John's is also uncooked.
So we had a little
combination.
AUDIENCE: Where are the best
tomatoes grown in the US?
SCOTT WIENER: That's an amazing,
amazing question.
So we actually did a taste test
of a bunch of different
commercially available
tomatoes.
This was, I think, two years
ago, maybe three years ago.
And I just went to different
grocery stores.
I went to restaurant
supply stores.
I grew some in my backyard.
We did everything.
And it was a double-blind
taste test.
So I labeled all these cans, got
rid of the paper labels,
gave them to somebody else,
who then served them up to
people in dishes labeled
G, I, F, whatever,
letters of the alphabet.
And we gave everybody a sheet.
And these are people-- pizzeria
owners, culinary
students, pizza writers, people
who I'm friends with
who just wanted to come over
and eat some tomatoes.
And everybody ranked the
sweetness, the acidity, the
color, the texture, and
the overall flavor.
And I have all that raw data.
If anybody wants to see it,
it's all on my website.
So you can see, there is not one
best tomato, because maybe
you want acidity, maybe you want
sweetness, and maybe you
want acidity and sweetness.
And that's fine, because
we got all
that on the data sheets.
Now, with all these tomatoes,
you see-- there's one that's
called San Marzano.
San Marzano is a big
name in tomatoes.
If anybody makes pizza
at home, you
probably use the San Marzano.
There's a lot of pride when
you use the San Marzano
tomato, because they talk about
it on The Food Network,
and you're just like, mmm,
I did it, Rachael Ray.
I did it.
San Marzano tomato, San
Marzano is just
a variety of tomato.
You can buy packages of San
Marzano tomato seeds and grow
them anywhere you want.
But the traditional
San Marzano is
grown in the southern--
so the soil of the southeastern
slope of Mount
Vesuvius, which is why some
of these cans say
San Marzano on them.
I know you can't all see
it from back there.
But there is one over here that
says San Marzano on the
bottom, but it says DOP, which
means Designated Origin of
Protection.
When it says DOP, it means that
it's guaranteed to be
from that region.
When it just says San Marzano--
like this one over
here, La Bella San Marzano,
is an excellent tomato,
but it's not a DOP.
It's not guaranteed to
be from that region.
Does it make it good?
Does it make it bad?
You'll find out in the results
that we have, because that's
what we were checking.
I wanted to know, does DOP
make a difference?
Does the other stuff
This one's called Sclafani,
which is this great
Italian-sounding name.
Those are grown in New Jersey.
But since a lot of people like
to buy local, they have
another label that says "Jersey
Fresh." And so you can
buy the same tomatoes, depending
on if you wanted to
have an "i" on the end of it,
or if you wanted to say it's
from New Jersey.
The same stuff.
And we checked them, and it was
funny, because our taste
testers put them pretty
close to each other.
And they didn't know.
So it's this roundabout thing,
although the DOP thing is so
interesting.
Somebody from the Italian
Consortium of San Marzano
tomatoes within the past eight
months came out with a
statement saying that 95% of San
Marzano tomatoes shipped
to America are fraud.
They're fraudulent tomatoes
that are packed by Italian
companies using Chinese tomatoes
or somewhere else,
and they're sent over here
because we don't have any laws
about that.
In Italy, they have law that if
it says DOP, it's got to be
from that region.
That's how you get the stamp.
If you get busted there,
you pay a fine.
Nobody's ever gotten arrested.
You just pay a little fine.
It's no big deal.
But if you get caught with
them here, nobody cares,
because you're just excited you
got San Marzano tomatoes.
Does somebody have a question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So all these tomatoes that I
see right here are canned.
SCOTT WIENER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I've heard thoughts,
ideas, rumors, that if you
have canned tomatoes, as opposed
to boxed crushed
tomatoes, you sometimes can get
a little bit of a metallic
taste to them.
Is that something that
you've seen?
Do you care?
Do you not care?
SCOTT WIENER: Oh, I care.
Yeah.
We tested Pomi, which is the
big boxed tomato company.
They don't make a boxed
whole tomato, at least
as far as I've seen.
We only tested whole tomatoes.
But yeah, since tomatoes are
very acidic, and since
anything you can has to have a
PH that's acidic enough to
stop bacteria from growing, to
prevent them from growing,
that's why you might get
tinniness out of a tomato.
But more often than not, you
can get rid of that by just
rinsing off the tomatoes
under some lukewarm
water, is really it.
Some of it is rumor.
Some of it is true.
But really, you taste it, and if
it tastes good, it's good.
Remember that these tomatoes--
there was a picture I showed you
with the tomatoes floating
in the can, the stuff that it's
floating in is usually
chopped up junk tomatoes.
So you probably don't really
want to eat those.
You want to eat the whole
tomatoes coming out of it.
That's why in the US now, a lot
of people like to buy a
canned sauce or a crushed
tomato, because then 100% of
the volume of that can will
be goods that you can use.
When you buy them as whole
tomatoes, you might get rid of
some of the juice.
And then you're not getting
100% of it.
So that crushed tomato
that's in the box,
the box may be good.
It may taste better.
But the tomatoes themselves,
I didn't find
it tastes any better.
And I actually find the other
ones to taste better.
But I would love to do
boxes, because these
take up a lot of room.
Look at all the wasted
space between them.
Boxes are really great
for stacking.
And really, I mean, the Pomi
company was at the
International Pizza Expo in
Las Vegas this past March.
And they were really excited
to show you how
much space it saves.
The same volume of tomatoes in
boxes is like this and in cans
is like this.
And that's what sells to people
at the International
Pizza Expo in Las Vegas,
which is a real thing
and not just a fantasy.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that you
don't feel there's a best
pizza [INAUDIBLE].
Let's say you just go to a
name-brand place, and you
don't know [INAUDIBLE]
wherever you end up because
you're on that block.
Are there some key signs that
you look for or key
indicators?
How do I just, on a one-off stop
and evaluate if this is a
place worth getting a slice?
SCOTT WIENER: Yeah, big time.
Well, the first thing I should
say to that is that it only
costs $2.75 to find out.
So really, when I find a place,
I don't really go in
and snoop around and
be like, hmm.
I go in and give it
a quick look.
And if it doesn't look bad,
then I drop the $2.50 and
check it out.
And then I know.
But telltale signs that you
might want to walk away-- heat
lamps, of course, having pieces
that look glazed over.
If there are more than 10
pizzas sitting out, then
there'd better be 10 people
sitting in that place.
Places that have fewer pizzas,
I feel like you can rely on
them more, just because the
turnover is going to be so
much faster and so
much cleaner.
So at a place like Joe's on
Carmine, they only have four
pizzas ever sitting out.
You're always going to
get a fresh slice.
You go to places like Suprema
has, I think they have 15 or
20, but there are always 20 or
30 people sitting there.
So you know that people
are eating it.
When you go to some
other places--
like, there's one, I just saw
paper in the window two days
ago, and I was like, great,
because they stunk--
you see so many pizzas sitting
out and then not enough
movement happening.
So yeah, you can't really judge
them by something like a
particular ingredient.
I wouldn't tell you to go to the
garbage can and look for
some of these cans.
Which by the way, to answer
the question that came up
before, the tomatoes that did
the best in our taste test,
the highest overall flavor,
were both from California.
They were both from central
California, which I was blown
away by because I really--
the DOPs came down very low.
They were very acidic.
The California ones
were very sweet.
So it may have just been
that we liked eating
them out of the can.
We liked eating it
fresh better.
Maybe cooked, it would've
been different.
But it just seemed like if you
like it out of the can, you're
going to like it after it's
been on a pizza for five
minutes in an oven.
So it was just really
interesting to see that happen.
The number-one tomato of our
whole list was not the $6 San
Marzano or the $3.48
San Marzano.
It was the $1.49 Trader Joe's
canned plum tomatoes.
I loved it.
I thought that was really,
really great.
But yeah, all these ingredients,
they come in all
because of social and economic
and historic reasons.
That's kind of why we end up
eating the way we eat.
It's not that somebody just
decided one day that this
would be a good topping
combination.
In Chicago, Chicago's such a big
pork city that sausage is
the thing to do in Chicago.
In New York, people are always
on the go and on the move, so
this is why we have
a slice culture.
We don't have deep-dish
pizza in New York.
There's no one doing
it except for two
locations of Pizzeria Uno.
And that's even debatable if
they're doing anything there.
But it's because we don't have
time to wait 45 minutes for a
pizza come out of an oven.
And that's how long it takes.
So much of it has to do with
the vibe of a city.
And right now, you see pizza by
the slice starting to pick
up a little bit more especially
in cities where you
have foot traffic.
It's the thing.
In Los Angeles, where everyone's
in their car, and
that's it, when you have
pizzerias that have valet
parking, which kills me, it's
not a big slice culture.
And when there is a place that
sells slices, everybody's
like, there's a place
that's the best now.
It's just like New York.
And it's not.
Cutting it up and selling it
to me one piece at a time
doesn't make it the
same as New York.
New York has all these myths and
legends about what makes
the pizza here so different.
And people say it's these old
ovens, or it's the water, or
anything like that.
And really what it comes down
to is that there's a long
tradition of making pizza and
that the pizza that was made
here originally is one step
removed from the original
pizza of southern Italy.
And if the Southern Italians had
gone to Moscow instead of
coming to New York and New Haven
and all these places in
the Northeastern US, then you
would've had a higher bar for
pizza there.
If, then, pizza got so popular
there that we got it, we would
have had third tier.
In the Midwest, you have a lot
of pizzerias that opened in
the '40s and '50s.
So when people say, oh, I got
this great place, it's been
around forever, it's been around
since 1958 or something
like that, it's not all
that long in the
American pizza landscape.
So places that have been around
that long are basing
themselves off of what
came before them.
And you're always going to
have this little bit of
degradation happening.
Until recently, until right
now, where we're really
looking straight down the line
on the future of pizza, at
places that are like--
earlier, before you guys came
in, we were talking about
Roberta's in Bushwick.
I mentioned Paulie Gee's before,
places like this--
Speedy Romeo in Clinton Hill--
where they're doing interesting
topping
combinations and using pizza
as a genre of food
and not as a dish.
Its pizza is sort of the
genre, and then you do
whatever you want to
do within that.
And you can play, and you can
do anything, Which is why
mashed potatoes work on pizza,
and people can admit that in
public, which is not
always the case.
Sometimes people are into
funky toppings.
Have you ever had peanut
butter on pizza?
They do that in New
Haven, too.
Weird.
And yet in New Haven, they're
all about having some of the
oldest pizza in America.
They're not bound to the
tradition, which I think is
really great.
And that sort of seems to be
where we're going in pizza
right now, is people are
pulling it into local
traditions, doing things
that are interesting.
I'm meeting with a guy
tomorrow from--
I don't even remember
where he's from.
But he wants to open
up a pizzeria.
It's going to be one of the only
pizzerias in his town.
And his concept, what he sent to
me, the list of ingredients
that he wants to use, it's a
lot of this local stuff.
And it's a lot of these dishes
that he's used to eating.
And it's great to put that onto
a pizza concept and kind
of see where it goes
from there.
But I know that the pizza
is dwindling.
And I don't know if you
guys have to stop
talking about pizza.
But if anybody has any
questions, I would love to try
to answer them, if possible.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you're not
going to say what's
your favorite pizza.
What's the worst pizza
you had in New York?
SCOTT WIENER: Oh, great.
Now, that's a good question.
The worst pizza I ever had in
New York was at a place-- and
I won't mention the name,
just because--
come up to me later, and I'll
write it on your arm with a
knife or something so
you never forget it.
And it's this place
in Crown Heights.
And I got an email from them
that was maybe the first
couple of months when I started
doing pizza tours.
And my biggest fear when I
started doing pizza tours is,
like, oh no, people are going
to think that I'm calling
myself an expert, which I've
never, ever done that.
Greg can call me what
he wants, but I
would never call myself--
every person who eats pizza
is a pizza expert.
But this person sort
of challenged me.
They said, if you really
consider yourself a pizza
person, you must have
gone to this place.
They make every slice by
hand and all this.
And I'm thinking, oh, they make
a slice one at a time?
Whoa.
And of course, they meant
the whole pie.
It was, whatever, nomenclature
difference.
That's OK.
So I went to this place.
I drove out there.
My friend was in the
car with me.
And I said, hang on here.
I know it looks weird, but
I've just got to go
in and eat a slice.
And if it's great, I'll take
you in, and it'll be great.
And I grab the slice.
It was very weird.
It felt like a school cafeteria
that had been empty
for six years, and the only
people that ever stood in
there were small children
or the two people
who served the pizza.
But they definitely did not make
it, because they didn't
know, really, anything about
what was going on.
And I ate it.
It was the only pizza that I've
ever taken a bite and
then not swallowed it.
And that was one of the worst
pizzas I've ever had.
I remember chewing
it a little bit.
And then I thought, is
something wrong?
What's wrong with me?
Am I having a heart
attack right now?
And it just turns out that
it was just real bad.
So I'll tell you
the name later.
But I'll put it this way.
You're never going
to go there.
You're never going to even
find it by accident.
So it's probably best
to just don't
ever go to Crown Heights.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: See, I'm
a wine lover.
So here, I open a new
bottle of wine.
[INAUDIBLE]
but I look at the color
and the [INAUDIBLE].
And I try to get the aromas
first before I
actually taste it.
So you being a pizza lover
[INAUDIBLE], when you hear
that there's a new pie that
you've just got to try, I'm
sure you don't just grab it and
take a bite right away.
SCOTT WIENER: I don't know
what else to do to it.
The thing about pizza is that
it's such a simple food, which
is what's so great, is that
anybody can over-think it
quite easily.
And that's why I try to not.
I mean, it's not like with
wine how there are things
chemically going on that you
need to prepare for yourself
to take in.
But with a slice of pizza, I
think almost the wrong thing
to do is to look at it and
over-think it first.
You could over-think it later.
I do that every day.
But I like to, first of all,
wait until the pizzeria is
open for two or three months.
Let them work out the kinks,
and then go in there, sit
down, eat a slice.
I wouldn't take it in--
I don't inspect angles of the
slice first, because the most
important thing at the end of
the day is not the oven.
It's not the type of
tomato they use.
It's how it tastes when you
eat it, because it's food.
I don't care how long you age
the steak or whatever.
If I eat it, and it's bad,
I don't like it.
Again, I don't care about-- so
many places say, we use this
type of flour, this
type of tomato.
We have the buffalo sitting
right there in the corner.
I don't care.
If it tastes good, it's good.
So many times, again-- this
happens on the West Coast a
lot-- they say, oh, we use
imported New York tap water.
That's why our pizza's
so good.
And I eat it, and I'm like,
man, you'd better start
importing some other water,
because I don't care what you
do, it's not good.
So really, no, jump in
there, take a bite,
and then that's it.
Is this a pizza that I want to
eat when I'm not hungry?
That's the big test of it.
Because when you're
real hungry,
anything could taste great.
You wolf down a couple slices.
You always got to go in--
whenever I'm doing pizza
tasting, raisins and pretzels
to take off the edge
before you go in.
Because if you drove two hours
for it, you can't go in there
without anything.
Yeah, what's up?
AUDIENCE: Any advice for
someone [INAUDIBLE]?
SCOTT WIENER: Definitely.
You make pizza at home?
What's your method?
Do you bake it on a
pan, on a stone?
You make your dough?
You buy your dough?
AUDIENCE: I have this
skillet [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: Yeah.
So this is a method that a lot
of people use that I've
actually never tried.
It's the skillet broiler
method, where
you heat up the skillet.
So you make a really hot surface
that you then put your
dough into.
That surface conducts heat
directly into the dough,
starts to bake, and then you
put it under the broiler to
give yourself top heat.
And yeah, that's
a great method.
I would say just overall, if you
make pizza at home, if you
make your dough, let
your dough relax.
If you start to stretch it, and
it shrinks back, cover it
and walk away from it.
Don't force it.
Always underwork your dough.
I mean, really, it sounds
ridiculous.
Even I hear it come out of my
mouth, it sounds ridiculous.
But I've got a friend, John
Arena, who owns a bunch of
pizzerias in Las Vegas.
And he's from out here, and he
always tells me the same thing
whenever I see him about.
We always watch people
working their dough.
And he always says, that
dough, it's alive.
And it is alive.
There's yeast in it.
It's constantly changing.
But he says it's alive in a
way that you're not even
thinking about.
If you torture it, if you harass
it, it remembers that.
It does.
And it will toughen up if
you overwork your dough.
It's why you work your dough
gently and easily and always
put it onto a hot surface,
like that skillet.
Or if you have a pizza stone,
the big mistake people make is
they have the pizza stone, and
they have the stone, they put
their pizza together, they put
it on the stone, and they put
the whole thing into the oven.
And the whole point of the stone
is to be hot so that
when you put your pizza onto
it, it immediately starts
baking the pizza from
the underside.
So I know a lot of people who
say, oh, I tried the stone,
but it just doesn't work.
And there's no way that it can't
work, because that's all
it's supposed to do
is be a heat soak.
That's it.
It doesn't work if you don't use
it correctly, because the
boxes never say to heat the oven
up for an hour, so nobody
would buy them.
But yeah, you've got to heat
it up a long time.
For home pizza making, I would
say just take it easy.
With toppings, less is more.
Take it easy.
Don't be in a rush.
Patience.
That's all it is.
And have fun.
I mean, even if you don't think
it's the best pizza
you've ever had, it's still
you made it, and it's just
going to taste better.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE: Maybe that'll
be the final question.
SCOTT WIENER: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: So Di Fara.
Often, if you don't get there
right at 11:30, and it's the
weekend, you wait a long
time for your pizza.
I have this notion that--
it's pretty good pizza.
Don't get me wrong.
But I have this notion that
people love it the way that
they do because by the time
they get it, they're so
hungry, and they've waited so
long, it's kind of like a
pizza Stockholm Syndrome.
SCOTT WIENER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
anything to that?
SCOTT WIENER: Oh,
without a doubt.
Part of it is that when you go
to any place that has hype,
that there's so much going on,
and you're looking around, you
see all these people.
When you're at Di Fara, there's
this amazing communal
thing that happens where half
the people are there looking
at the other half being like,
oh, it's your first time?
I'll show you.
That kind of thing.
And then the other half are
like, oh, what do we do?
Where do I go?
It's smoky in here, and
my eyes are crying.
What am I going to do?
And I love watching
that whole scene.
But the best way to approach
Di Fara is definitely not
hungry, because you'll always
be hungry by the
time it comes out.
And if you're bringing somebody
there who's never
been there, don't hype it up.
Don't tell them anything.
Sometimes I'll get tours of,
like, a family from Australia
or something like that,
or from Texas.
I had a family from Texas.
They never heard anything
about it.
I told them where to meet me.
I said, meet me in front
of this place.
I didn't say a word.
And they ate it, and they were
able to kind of discover it
for themselves, which
is kind of rare.
It's rare around here to
find somebody who's
never heard about it.
At least there are myths going
around where people say, oh,
what about that place where
there's that guy?
And he only makes 10 pizzas
a day, or whatever.
When you're going to a place
like Di Fara, or anything that
has that hype, you just have to
bring those pretzels, bring
those raisins.
Or water.
Water is good.
When you're getting hungry, just
drink some of that water.
And at Di Fara--
this is probably the last thing
I should tell you guys,
because I know you guys probably
have to work today.
But I'm going to stay here
and eat all this.
But at a place like Di Fara, the
best method is you go in,
and you look down
at the counter.
And sometimes, there's
a slice pie.
And sometimes, there are slices
there that are unclaimed.
Jump on that, and then put your
order in for the opposite.
So if there's a round pie
sitting there, order a
square whole pie.
If there's a square sitting
there for slices, order the
round whole pie, just so you
can get the best of both
worlds, especially if you're
taking somebody there who's
never been there before.
You've got to jump on it.
You've got to walk right in.
And if you get there at 11:30,
they'll seat you.
And they usually have
a pie ready to go.
They're on top of it, although
they make it seem like they
love drawing it out.
It's just that he really just
won't move any faster.
And you don't want him to,
because it already comes out
kind of funky and burnt, and
that's the character of it.
You don't want it to be
burnt by accident.
You want it to be a little
charred because of the scene
and because of what it's like.
So if you guys have any other
questions or anything, you can
always send me an email.
My email's just
scott@scottspizzatours.com And
I keep a blog on my website.
The website is
scottspizzatours.com.
You can easily keep in touch on
Twitter, @scottspizzatour,
or the Facebook, or
any of that stuff.
Or just ask Greg.
He can give you my
phone number.
You can text me, hey,
what's the best
pizza in New York City?
Just a quick question.
Don't think you've
ever heard this.
What's the best pizza
in New York?
Drives me crazy.
But anyway, guys, thanks for
coming and for eating pizza.
And thanks to Greg and Melissa
for putting this together,
because if you guys would have
seen some of the emails of
organization for pizzas,
it would've blown
your mind right there.
AUDIENCE: What's the best
pizza tour in New York?